feuerwerk am hellichten tage ist ein
film des chinesischen regisseurs li aus
china der auf der berlinale mit dem
goldenen bären ausgezeichnet wurde
er spielt in einer industrie provinz im
nordwesten chinas
leo van spielten held des films einen
polizisten ein letztes mal trifft er
sich mit seiner frau in einem
hotelzimmer bevor die ehe geschieden
wird
die scheidung des ehepaars und die suche
nach der herkunft der leichenteile die
auf dem förderband eines kohlebergwerks
auftauchen sind die zwei
handlungsstränge die in finanz film zu
einer düsteren kriminalgeschichte
zusammenwachsen
kulisse ist das industrie revier dass
die klassengesellschaft gleich mit
porträtiert der polizist von seinem
kommissars job in die abgründe des
chinesischen prekariats als zwei seiner
assistenten getötet werden
schnelles geld
nur zurück
blackpool den ice heißt der englische
titel des films dessen eigentliches
rückgrat die bilder sind die garküchen
am stadtrand oder die eisbahn die für
ein paar man das glück einer
durchtanzten abendstunde gewährt
die szene auf dem riesenrad ist eine
hommage an carol reeds kinoklassiker der
dritte mann von 1949
von dort oben ist ein heller leuchtet
der vergnügungs palast zu sehen
er heißt feuerwerk am hellichten tage